♪♪
Let's get to the news.
President Biden was photographed
on Thursday
picking a dandelion
from the White House lawn
and giving it
to First Lady Dr. Jill Biden,
and right about there is when
Kamala Harris called
for a Bible.
"Oop!
False alarm!
Nope.
He's getting back up.
Yep.
No, just picking a flower."
The Kentucky Derby
was this weekend.
"And they're off!"
said Americans, about their TVs.
According to his advisors,
former President Trump
is still challenging the results
of the 2020 election
and has called for a hand
recount of 2 million ballots
cast in Arizona's
largest county,
which brings us
to a segment called
"Seth Tries to Think
of Literally Anything
More Pathetic."
♪♪
Asking your mom to prom?
No.
Helping the guy your wife had
an affair move?
No.
Asking your mom to prom
and she's already going
with someone else?
[ Laughter ]
No, I can't do it.
-This has been...
-I cannot believe Scollins
wrote that joke
and then did the voice-over.
[ Laughter ]
Is there anyone --
Is there anyone working here
on quality control?
[ Laughs ]
And a real flat read, too.
[ Laughter ]
Let's be honest.
It's not like --
It's not like he's
our staff's Morgan Freeman.
"Well, we had to let him do it.
I can't believe he wasn't busy
with other voice-over work."
♪♪
President Biden said last week
that he was not given
advance notice of the raid
on former President Trump's
personal attorney
Rudy Giuliani's home,
and I would have believed him,
if he hadn't had popcorn all
over his suit.
U.S. troops began their
withdrawal last week
from Afghanistan after nearly
20 years occupying the country.
To give you an idea
of how long that is...
That's right -- U.S. troops
began their withdrawal
last week from Afghanistan.
Biden has plenty of reasons,
but number one is definitely
those YouTube videos where they
surprise a dog.
[ As Biden ]
Aww!
Dang it, gets me every time!
Former president Trump
was reportedly presented
with a 24-page proposal
to launch his own
multibillion-dollar
media company
and, under his leadership,
in a few years, it could become
a multimillion-dollar company.
After visiting former
President Jimmy Carter
at his home on Thursday,
President Biden told reporters
that they, "Sat and talked
about the old days."
Like when they worked
side-by-side
to try to bring down crime
and gas prices
and that mammoth.
According to Politico,
17% of President Biden's
White House staffers
have degrees
from Harvard University.
Said the other 83%,
"Uh, we know."
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Pennsylvania
announced last week
that they arrested a man
after they discovered
$1 million worth
of crystal meth,
six so-called ghost guns,
and Nazi paraphernalia
during a raid.
And, now, the man
is trying to decide
if he should accept a plea deal
or just go ahead
and run for Congress.
The NYPD recently announced
that it will no longer use
its controversial
so-called robot dog
and, once again,
Travis stepped up to the plate.
-He was my dog.
I'll do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Real hot Monday for Scollins.
And, finally, the Italian
motorcycle company Benelli
recently launched a new scooter,
called the Dong,
and it's a pretty good scooter,
except in cold weather.
♪♪
President Biden received
the daily intelligence
briefing this morning.
It was just, "So, they released
the Carter picture."
[ Laughter ]
How is this the first
we're hearing about the Bidens
being 40 feet tall?
[ Laughter ]
They look like
a ventriloquist act.
You know that dandelion picture
from the other day?
That was an oak tree.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced yesterday
that President Biden
will deliver
the commencement address
later this month
at the U.S. Coast Guard
Academy graduation.
And, while we're on the subject,
is it too late to change
your Major?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
Don't make me send you back
to Scranton!
A White House announced
yesterday --
excuse me, the White House,
or a White House.
[ Laughter ]
We should stop being so specific
about which one it is.
The White House announced
yesterday that President Biden
is raising the annual
refugee limit to 62,500.
Also rising?
Tucker Carlson's blood pressure.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
asked fifth graders
at an elementary school
in Virginia yesterday
what they wanted to be
when they grew up.
Said students,
"Covered by a healthcare plan
that isn't tied
to my employment."
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
yesterday suspended all
of the state's coronavirus
restrictions, and said,
"We are no longer
in a state of emergency,"
adding,
"but it's still Florida, so,
give it a couple of days."
Microsoft founder Bill Gates
announced yesterday
that he and his wife, Melinda,
will get a divorce,
after being married
for 27 years.
Apparently,
it was an accumulation
of lots of little things,
like how Bill would never
empty the recycling.
[ Laughter ]
That's what you get for hiring
people who used to work in IT.
[ Laughter ]
Researchers in Germany
recently named
a new bacteria that is linked
to lung parasites
after the Pokémon tool
Poké Balls
because they're a similar shape.
Said one German doctor --
[ German accent ] Bad news.
Ve didn't catch 'em all.
[ Laughter ]
I should know.
I freestyled there.
The joke was not
for a German doctor
and, the last minute,
I was like, "You know what?
Let's let it rip.
What's the worst
that could happen?"
And then, you saw
what the worst was.
[ Laughter ]
A man in England
was arrested last week
after a four miles per hour
police chase,
in a narrow boat on a canal,
that lasted for eight miles,
which means that,
by the time they caught him,
the statute of limitations
had run out.
Eight people who were involved
in the torch relay
for the Tokyo Olympic Games
have tested positive
for the coronavirus.
Well, it's hard news to hear,
but, at least,
the contact tracing
will be easy.
And, finally,
according to a new report,
the number of customers
who subscribe
to AOL's dial-up
Internet service is,
"in the low thousands,"
which is also their average age.
♪♪
Facebook's Oversight Board
announced today
that it will uphold
the company's decision
to suspend former
President Trump's account.
So whatever else
you think of the guy,
he did find a way
to leave Facebook.
President Biden
announced yesterday
he will change the country's
coronavirus vaccination
strategy.
He's going
with reverse psychology.
[ As Biden ]
Fine, don't get one.
No one wants
to hang out with you
in an indoor setting, anyway.
In a new interview,
Republican Senator Josh Hawley
said he does not regret
pumping his fist
to cheer on the pro-Trump mob
that stormed the Capitol
on January 6th.
He honestly never thought
anyone would find him inspiring.
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
said recently that Republicans
are willing to negotiate
with President Biden
over his $2.3 trillion
infrastructure proposal.
McConnell said there might be
some wiggle room
around the placement
of the decimal point.
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy said recently
that the woke movement in this
country "has got to stop"
because it has led
to an absolute epidemic
of old white guys saying "woke."
Second Gentleman Doug Emhoff
traveled to Pennsylvania today
to meet
with small business owners,
as opposed to President Biden,
who spent the weekend
meeting
with small peanut farmers.
I'm sorry.
It's a weird picture.
I fear to look,
yet I cannot turn away.
President Biden said this week
that, during his trip
to Europe in June,
he hopes and expects
to meet with Russian
President Vladmir Putin.
"That can be arranged," said
a paperweight on his desk.
According to a match.com survey,
71% of single people
have not had sex
since the coronavirus
pandemic started,
and 91% of married people.
What do you think, Shoemaker,
am I in the 9% or the 91%?
-No, I know.
[ Laughter ]
-Shoemaker!
Star quarterback Tom Brady
said recently
that he would trade two
of his seven Super Bowl rings
to have won a championship
at the end of his 2007
undefeated season.
"Sorry, but we already
made a deal,"
said Satan.
Producers have announced
a new spinoff
of the "Law & Order" series,
entitled "Law & Order
for the Defense."
Turns out Dick Wolf isn't
even close to "dun-dun."
Every time you think
we've used the "dun-dun"
as a punch line for the last,
it comes back around.
According to new research,
eating more nuts
can lead to weight loss
and better appetite control.
[ Clattering ]
Sorry, that was just every one
of my male writers
trying to get
to cue cards first.
A 1,692-foot-long
pedestrian suspension bridge
recently opened in Portugal
and takes at least
four minutes to cross,
not to mention
three pairs of underwear.
And, finally,
according to a new study,
men with larger noses
may also have larger penises.
In case you're wondering why
this guy looks so smug
all the time.
♪♪
President Biden visited
a 70-year-old bridge
in Lake Charles, Louisiana,
today
while pitching his jobs
and infrastructure plan
because, if Biden's proof
of anything,
it's how much good
a few thousand dollars
in bridge work can do for you.
President Biden went
to a Mexican restaurant
in Washington yesterday
in honor of Cinco de Mayo.
He had the enchiladas
and Major had the mariachi band.
[ Laughter ]
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell said yesterday
that, "100% of my focus
is on stopping
the Biden administration."
Oh, really? I don't remember
seeing you there.
Put your money
where your mouth is, bud.
Also, where is your mouth?
Allies of Rudy Giuliani
have reportedly asked
former President Trump
to pay Giuliani
for representing him
through the 2020 election.
Um, do they know
what kind of job he did?
That's like the captain
of the Titanic asking,
"So, where do I
submit my invoice?"
A woman was recently arrested
at the Atlanta airport
after officials discovered
3 pounds of cocaine
hidden in the bottom
of seven pairs of shoes.
In her defense, 3 pounds
of cocaine is the only way
to make your connection
at that airport.
The fitness company Peloton
recalled two of its treadmills
yesterday
after dozens of injuries
involving children
were reported.
That's crazy. Who can afford
a Peloton and children?
A woman in Missouri
recently discovered
a World War II-era Japanese bomb
while gardening,
which came as a surprise because
she planted cruise missiles.
[ Laughter ]
Employees of a coronavirus
testing facility
at an Indonesian airport
were arrested yesterday
for allegedly washing
and reusing
nasal swabs for passengers.
Well, at least
they know who's got COVID now.
"Looks like, uh, yeah...
everyone."
And, finally, Mother's Day
is this weekend,
according to six voicemails
from your mother.
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]